Ich habe eine wichtige Frage an euch.
* Titelmelodie *
Ich habe eine Frage an euch.
Falls das hier das erste Video sein
sollte, dass ihr mit mir seht,
gebt mir die Chance, schaut es
euch trotzdem bis zum Ende an.
Auf den ersten Blick wirkt
das Ganze hier vielleicht
wie nur "ein
Hundertausend-Abo-Special",
aber eigentlich
ist es viel mehr als das.
Also erlaubt mir, ein
kleines bisschen auszuholen,
bevor ich euch die Frage stelle.
maiLab läuft echt gut.
Danke, Freunde der Sonne.
Und ich werde gefragt:
Wie macht ihr das?
Und ich antworte: Wir versuchen,
guten Content zu machen.
Das klingt auf den ersten Blick
ziemlich banal.
But it's it.
Auf den zweiten Blick ist guter
Content nicht unbedingt notwendig
für Erfolg, im Sinne von Reichweite.
Es gibt genug Kanäle, bei denen der
Content eindeutig zweitrangig ist.
Aber das hier ist unser Ansatz.
Wir möchten guten Coentent machen.
Okay.
Und wie macht man jetzt
guten Content?
Ich verrate euch
jetzt mal ein Geheimnis.
Ich könnte jetzt sagen, dass
ich besonders leidenschaftlich
und motiviert bin, dass ich
besonders viel Zeit und Liebe
in diesen Kanal stecke.
Auch wenn das alles sehr wahr ist,
gibt's noch eine weitere Geheimzutat.
Nämlich: mein Geheimnis.
Ich
bin
frustriert.
Ich bin frustriert.
Und bevor ihr mich Keksemojis
überhäuft, um mich aufzumuntern,
lasst mich erst mal erklären,
was ich damit meine.
Mai präsentiert: eine unvollständige
Liste von Dingen,die sie frustrieren.
Warum lässt man es zu,
dass Fakten und Meinungen
gleichwertig behandelt werden?
Sei es eine klassische
Online-Kommentarspalte.
Oder eine öffentlich-rechtliche
Politik-Talkshow,
oder das Weiße Haus.
Warum lässt man die Debatten
von denjenigen bestimmen,
die am lautesten schreien
oder am härtesten triggern
und nicht von denjenigen,
mit den besten Argumenten?
Frust!
In Köln sind aktuell
wieder die Masern ausgebrochen,
eine Krankheit,
die ulkig aussehen mag,
aber die so was von nicht lustig ist.
Eine Krankheit,
die tödlich enden kann.
Wir haben hier Eltern, die
ihre Kinder nicht impfen lassen.
Die damit nicht nur das Leben ihrer
eigenen Kinder auf's Spiel setzen,
sondern das Leben aller Menschen,
die aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
nicht geimpft werden können
und die sich auf uns verlassen.
Frust.
Das Internet ist eine Plattform,
auf der theoretisch jeder mit jedem
in Kontakt treten kann.
Doch wir verlernen unsere Fähigkeit
zu diskutieren, weil wir nur nach
persönlicher Bestätigung suchen.
Ich könnte mich zum Beispiel über
Impfskeptiker lustig machen
oder sie als dumm beschimpfen
und davon von meinen Freunden
Applaus ernten.
Aber dadurch gehen die Masern
in Köln auch nicht weg.
Wir predigen immer nur den Bekehrten.
Ich kann sehr gut verstehen,
dass man seinem Frust auch manchmal
einfach Luft machen möchte und muss.
Aber das kann nicht das einzige Ziel
von Kommunikation sein.
Das Ziel muss Aufklärung sein
und nicht Bestätigung.
Frust!
Warum gehören Naturwissenschaften
in unserer Wahrnehmung
nicht zur Allgemeinbildung?
Warum ist Chemie Freakwissen,
das zwar ganz beeindruckend ist,
aber nicht relevant?
Ich kann verstehen,
wenn einen Redoxreaktionen
nicht in Ekstase versetzt.
Aber Wissenschaft
ist doch viel mehr als das.
Es geht um das kritische,
objektive Beobachten dieser Welt.
Es geht darum, Wissen zu sammeln,
damit man
logische Hypothesen aufstellen kann,
damit man diese Hypothesen
systematisch testen kann.
Damit man faktische Belege
sammeln kann.
Damit man sich skeptisch
hinterfragen kann immer wieder,
um sich weiterzuentwickeln.
Ohne diesen, ich nenne es
"wissenschaftlichen Spirit",
wäre die Menschheit
am (flüstert) Arsch.
Ja, ja. "Wissenschaft ist wichtig."
(leiernder Ton)
"Wissenschaft ist wichtig."
Sagt das nicht so daher!
Wissenschaft ist nicht wichtig,
Wissenschaft ist essentiell.
Jeder muss ihren Kern
verstanden haben.
Das ist Lebenskompetenz.
Warum sieht das niemand?
Von einem intellektuellen,
gebildeten Menschen
erwartet man heutzutage,
dass dieser Mensch
politisch interessiert
und gebildet ist.
Erwartet man von diesen Menschen
auch, dass er naturwissenschaftlich
interessiert und gebildet ist?
Nein!
Warum?
Diese Trennung...
...von Wissenschaft - als
etwas theoretisch Akademisches -
und der echten Welt,
der relevanten Welt...
Diese Trennung macht mich fertig.
Ich rede zugegebenermaßen fast
immer nur von Naturwissenschaften.
Weil es eben mein Gebiet ist.
Aber was ist mit Geistes-
und Sozialwissenschaften?
Wo ist die Wissenschaft, wenn z.B.
über Flüchtlingspolitik geredet wird?
Wo sind die Fakten und
die wissenschaftlichen Belege?
Warum kann man nicht Emotionen haben
und trotzdem auf Fakten schauen?
Bei naturwissenschaftlichen Themen
ist das einfacher nachzuvollzuiehen.
Nehmen wir als Beispiel Gentechnik
oder autonomes Fahren.
Diese Technologien kommen
bzw. sie sind schon da.
Wir brauchen vernünftige Regularien.
Wir müssen wichtige politische und
juristische Entscheidungen treffen.
Diese Menschen, die diese
Entscheidung treffen, sind die dazu
fachlich überhaupt in der Lage?
Haben sie einen
ausreichenden Überblick
über die wissenschaftlichen Fakten?
Und gibt es genügend Austausch
zwischen ihnen
und den wissenschaftlichen
Expert*innen?
Meine steile These: Nein.
Frust.
Warum muss immer
alles schwarz und weiß sein?
Warum sind so wenige Menschen
dazu bereit zu differenzieren?
Ich wünschte,
jede gesellschaftliche Debatte
wäre wie der Diskussionsteil
in einem wissenschaftlichen Paper.
Nehmen wir eine
wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichung
aus dem Bereich Chemie.
Da hat man in der Regel
mit physiko-chemischen Messtechniken
Daten erfasst.
Also Zahlen und Messwerte.
Was die Sache ja schon mal ein gutes
Stück klarer macht als die meisten
gesellschaftlichen
oder politischen Diskussionen.
Trotzdem hat dieses Paper
einen Diskussionsteil,
wo lang und breit diskutiert wird,
was diese Zahlen und Messwerte
bedeuten könnten.
Und was auch nicht.
Und ich möchte nicht damit sagen,
dass Wissenschaftler*innen
die besseren Menschen sind.
Oh, nein.
Aber, wir wurden nun mal
jahrelang dazu trainiert,
dazu gezwungen,
jede unserer Aussagen zu belegen.
Und zwar noch nicht einmal mit
einem "hab ich gemessen, ist so".
Sondern differenziert
und selbstkritisch.
Und das ist erst mal gut so.
Aber...
... jetzt sitzen die ganzen
Wissenschaftler*innen
in ihren Büros oder Laboren.
Und schauen zu, wie im Internet
die größte *Piep* verbreitet wird.
Und sagen nichts.
Sie sind zu vorsichtig
bzw. zu differenziert,
um sich einzumischen.
Und das geht so nicht.
Man kann differenziert sein
und eine Haltung haben.
Man muss Haltung zeigen.
* Stöhnt*
Frust!
Es gibt vieles,
das mich aufregt und frustriert.
Deswegen habe ich das Labor
verlassen und mich Vollzeit
der Wissenschaftskommunikation
verschrieben.
Ich rede über Wissenschaft,
wann und wo immer ich auch nur kann.
Ich mache das hier auf YouTube.
Ich mache das auch im Fernsehen,
ich schreibe gerade ein Buch.
Und ich arbeite als Dozentin.
Der Frust ist
meine Motivation geworden.
Aber, bei allem, was ich tue, seid
ihr natürlich ein wesentlicher Teil
der Gleichung.
Kommunikation ist ja sinnlos
ohne Menschen, die zuhören.
Und die Gedankenanstöße aufnehmen und
die Diskussion auch weiterführen.
Aber v.a. seid ihr diejenigen
Menschen, die meinen Frust
in Hoffnung und Optimismus umwandeln.
Und in eine Motivation,
so weiterzumachen.
Ich muss wirklich sagen, ihr
seid diejenigen, die meinen Job
so erfüllend machen.
Hier kommen wir zu euch und auch
gleich zu meiner Frage an euch.
Vorher möchte ich noch kurz etwas
zum Hundertausend-Abo-Meilenstein
sagen.
maiLab ist der in der letzten Zeit
ziemlich stark gewachsen.
Damit hat sich auch die
Außenwahrnehmung geändert.
Dieser Kanal
ist jetzt ziemlich legit.
Wir wurden ausgezeichnet,
wir haben jetzt diese eindrückliche
sechsstellige Zahl da stehen.
Und jetzt werde ich plötzlich nicht
mehr gefragt,warum ich YouTube mache.
Und das ist ziemlich interessant.
Eine Reichweite
scheint zu rechtfertigen,
was ich hier auf YouTube mache.
Dieser Gedanke ist eigentlich
ziemlich gefährlich.
Denn wir am Anfang schon gesagt,
haben Reichweite und Qualität
erst mal noch nichts
miteinander zu tun.
Es gibt Kanäle
mit riesiger Reichweite,
die einfach nur Bullshit machen.
Und es gibt Kanäle,
die großen Mehrwert haben,
aber eine kleine Reichweite.
Trotzdem bedeuten mir die
100.000 Abonnenten ziemlich viel.
Warum?
Geht es hier um Fame?
Nein!
Ich habe offensichtlich kein Problem
damit, im Mittelpunkt zu stehen,
sonst hätte ich
nicht mit YouTube begonnen.
Aber Fame ist keine
persönliche Motivation für mich.
Es ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes
dabei, wenn man das verfolgt.
Überhaupt nichts Schlimmes dabei.
Nur, es ist für mich persönlich
nicht das, wofür ich mir morgens
meinen Wecker stelle.
Geht es um Geld?
Nein!
Bei Funk werde ich nicht nach
Reichweite oder Klicks bezahlt.
Deswegen bin ich froh,
dass ich da unabhängig bin
und in keinen Interessenskonflikt
geraten muss.
Wo ich Content gegen Klickbarkeit
Abwegen müsste.
Aber. Es geht um "Representen".
Represent.
Passt auf, es frustriert mich,
dass Internet-Content heutzutage
nur auf Reichweite reduziert wird.
Weil Reichweite wiederum nur
auf Money und Fame reduziert wird.
Dabei ist Reichweite
doch viel mehr als das.
Es geht doch am Ende um den Inhalt
und wie viele du damit erreichst.
Oder nicht?
Wenn ich sehe, wie viel YouTube
geschaut wird und wie viele Klicks
an Inhalte gehen, die
letztendlich schädlich sind...
Schädlich, weil sie unkritisch,
undifferenziert oder manipulativ sind
Dann will ich
verdammt noch mal da mitreden.
Wir brauchen mehr
wissenschaftlichen Spirit.
Deswegen hoffe ich,
dass unsere Community,
die Freunde der Sonne
und Keksemojis, weiter wächst.
Ich bin auf einer Mission, Freunde.
Die Science-Seuche
hat gerade erst angefangen.
Und jetzt zu euch.
Ihr unterschätzt die Macht,
die ihr als Zuschauer habt.
Ich kann mir jetzt Missionen
und Visionen einbilden,
das bringt alles nicht,
solange es keiner sehen möchte.
Deswegen nicht nur hier bei maiLab,
sondern wann auch immer ihr im Netz
über guten Content stolpert, das muss
bei aller Liebe kein Science sein.
Alles, was Mehrwert hat...
Seid so gut!
Liket es.
Kommentiert es, teilt es.
Schreibt ein Lob an den Creator,damit
er sich weiterhin motiviert fühlt,
so weiter zu machen.
Seid Teil der Seuche!
Der guten Seuche.
Ich weigere mich, das Internet
undifferenzierten,
unlogischen und ziellosen
Debatten zu überlassen.
Die Vernunft hat auch eine Stimme.
Sie ist, weil sie so vernünftig ist,
etwas leiser und höflicher.
Aber nein, die Stimme
der Vernunft muss lauter werden.
Wir brauchen
eine Seuche der Vernunft.
Das ist ab jetzt meine Frage an euch:
Was würdet ihr
mit 100.000 Abonnenten machen?
Wenn euch 100.000 Menschen zuhören,
was ist es, das ihr ihnen
sagen müsstet?
Was regt euch auf,
was frustriert euch?
Was muss sich ändern eurer Meinung
nach und was könnte sich ändern,
wenn doch nur 100.000 Menschen
zuhören könnten?
Also, was würdet ihr mit
100.000 Abonnenten machen?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Wir sehen uns in der Endcard.
Auf die Seuche der Vernunft.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
Es wird mal wieder Zeit,
Keksemojis zu verteilen.
Wenn nicht bei diesem Video,
wann dann?
Aber, seht es mir nach, dass
ich gerade so ein bisschen
in dem Stress meines Lebens stecke.
Weil die Deadline für mein Buch
kurz bevorsteht.
Aber, an dem Donnerstag,
an dem dieses Video online geht,
werde ich für 1 bis 2 Stunden
mal in die Kommentare sliden
und Keksemojis verteilen.
An diejenigen, die
die 100.000-Abo-Frage beantworten.
Wir sehen uns also da oder
spätestens nächsten Donnerstag.
Bis dahin: Bleibt sicher!